what have you learned from launching and
running com Ai and Tiny Corp so this
starting a company from an idea and
scaling it and by the way I'm all in on
Tiny Box so I'm I'm your I'll I guess
it's pre-order only now I want to make
sure it's good I want to make sure that
like the thing that I deliver is like
not going to be like a Quest 2 which you
buy and use twice I mean it's better
than a quest which you bought and used
less than once statistically well if
there's a beta program for a tiny box
I'm into sounds good
so I won't be the whiny uh you know I'll
be the tech tech savvy user of the Tiny
Box just to be in the early days what
have you learned from building these
companies
for the longest time a comma I asked why
why you know why did I start a company
why did I do this
um
that you know
what else was I gonna do
so you like
you like bringing ideas to life
with comma
it really started as an ego battle with
Elon
ah I wanted to beat him I like I saw a
worthy adversary you know he was a
worthy adversary who I can beat at
self-driving cars and like I think we've
kept pace and I think he's kept ahead I
think that's what's ended up happening
there
um but I do think comma is I mean comes
profitable
it's like
and like when this drive GPT stuff
starts working that's it there's no more
like bugs in a loss function like right
now we're using like a hand-coded
simulator there's no more bugs this is
going to be it like this is the run-up
to driving I hear a lot of really uh a
lot of props
comma it's it's so it's it's better than
FSD and autopilot in certain ways it has
a lot more to do with which field you
like we lowered the price on the
hardware to 14.99 you know how hard it
is to ship reliable consumer electronics
that go on your windshield we're doing
more than like
most cell phone companies how'd you pull
that off by the way shipping a product
that goes in a car I know I have a I
have a I have an smt line it's all I
make all the boards in-house
quality control I care I'm mentally
about it you're basically a mom and pop
shop with great testing our head of open
pilot is great at like you know okay I
want all the commentaries to be
identical yeah
and yeah I mean you know it's look it's
14.99 it 30 day money back guarantee it
will it will blow your mind at what it
can do is it hard to scale
you know what there's kind of downsides
to scaling it people are always like why
don't you advertise
our mission is to solve self-driving
cars while the lifting ship will
intermediaries my mission has nothing to
do with selling a million boxes
it's Audrey
do you think it's possible that uh
common gets sold
only if I felt someone could accelerate
that mission
and wanted to keep it open source
and like not just wanted to I don't
believe what anyone says I believe in
Santos if a company wanted to buy comma
with their incentives or to keep it open
source but
comma doesn't stop at the cars the cars
are just the beginning the device is a
human head the device has two eyes two
ears it breathes air as a mouth
so you think this goes to embodied
robotics we have we sell common bodies
too you know they're very they're very
rudimentary
but one of the problems that we're
running into is that the comma 3 has
about as much intelligence as a b
if you want a human's worth of
intelligence you're going to need a tiny
rack not even a tiny box you're going to
need like a tiny rack maybe even more
how does that how do you put legs on
that you don't and there's no way you
can you you connect to it wirelessly
so you put your tiny box or your tiny
Rack in your house and then you get your
comma body or your comma body runs the
models on that
it's it's close right it's not you don't
have to go to some Cloud which is you
know 30 milliseconds away you go to a
thing which is 0.1 milliseconds away so
the AI girlfriend
will have like a central Hub in the home
I mean eventually if you fast forward 20
30 years the mobile chips will get good
enough to run these AIS but
fundamentally it's not even a question
of putting legs on a tiny box because
how are you getting 1.5 kilowatts of
power on that thing right yeah so you
need they're very uh synergistic
businesses I also want to build all of
commas training computers right at comma
builds training computers right now we
use commodity Parts I think I can do it
cheaper so we're going to build a tiny
Corp is going to not just sell tiny
boxes Tiny Box is the consumer version
but I'll build training data centers too